[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joe montana joining us on the program
good morning joe how are you
good morning mr patrick how are you
going okay are you more invested in
watching notre dame or the 49ers
um
that probably both um i haven't seen
much to be the team play
okay
do you care to watch football like did
you were you ever really a big fan
yeah i enjoy watching it the problem is
we've just been we've just been on on
the
you know on the road a little bit here
uh moving around and
uh we you know we finally got
we cancelled a couple trips over to
europe and we finally got over there for
a little bit and spent some time so
missed a few weekends and
had some friends come by last weekend
for
we were up in the wine country so
i missed that weekend
so i catch one every now and then here
and there but uh no i i think i love
watching the game i'm not sure jennifer
does that uh as much as i do by far but
hopefully when the boys come over then i
get to turn the tv up back on are you
recognized in europe
um
mostly by americans that are there you
know when you get into larger cities
but um not not as much you know but i
think what happens is people go um
by the time you get past them there
you can't remember
it's all the great hair and boss in here
and you like to wear your jersey when
you go overseas
yeah you know
i bring both the red
home it away
did you save anything from your super
bowls
um
[Music]
i have it was funny as i say the jerseys
um the one the red jersey
is um the same jersey i wore
i wore the same one twice the white one
i didn't the first one when i did i
don't believe i saved
but the last one yeah but the red jersey
is funny because we
if you notice in the second time we wore
them the
stripes are different on my jersey than
someone else's on the rest of the team
because
jennifer packed
und in my suitcase as a surprise that
jersey
so i wore that jersey instead of the
other red ones that everybody else had
arms from the first time we wore red but
that would be a uniform violation and
you would be fined now joe
yes i know
[Laughter]
but it would have taken him too long to
figure it out
but
look i look boy they gave us so much
crap about our socks being right height
and all the time and the stripe has to
be certain i mean i watched the teams
today i was watching the chiefs the
other day man some socks are all white
some are all red all pulled up depends
on how they pull them up they go isn't
that a fine today i thought
so uniform yeah they didn't do that back
then but
i was uh talking about you know scottie
pippen has been kind of on the warpath
he's you know criticizing michael jordan
you know and
you know for whatever reason or his
reasons but i was wondering if you and
jerry rice did did you guys ever have
conflict of
you know who was getting most attention
or who deserved the most attention like
did you did you have any ego
fights there no
no not at all you know
every now and then
uh like all wide receivers if you don't
if they don't get the ball enough you
know except for jt never said a word on
the other side but after a while like
jerry never said a word
he was quiet
and he was quiet as out there and then
you would go jerry if you threw the ball
somewhere jr did you have him and he go
oh yeah and then you you turn on the
film there's like three guys on him
yeah cause i didn't know if there was a
you know like whose team is it or
you know because jerry's recognized as
maybe the greatest player of all time or
certainly in that conversation so i i
didn't know if there was any of that
with you guys
no never you mean there was a like i
said occasion if the game was tight or
something or we were losing and he
wasn't getting the ball and
you know he might say something
or get a little upset but in most cases
he
i mean
it was hard to get words out of them you
know to try to
you know
even to find out whether he was hey i
can beat him on this or you know usually
you talk but well there for the longest
time he was
you know he was pulling teeth to get him
to talk to you so but it was more
talking that
i would talk to him and
then eventually he started coming back
around starting understanding that maybe
we need to communicate so and i think
things got um you know
better for us to understand what each of
us were thinking on play so
was pretty good you were talking about
rule changes and how they prolonged tom
brady's career what do you think the
biggest rule change
is that's allowed him to play as long as
he has
i think taking away those the big hit i
mean that
you know years ago you used to be the
guy who could stand there
and
deliver the ball
accurately down the field when
you know that guy who's
three feet away from me who's gonna not
only is he gonna hit you but he's gonna
plant you and land on top of you
and that's where all the injuries are i
think as a quarterback we're the only
guy that's standing still
that gets hit
most everyone else has a chance to make
a move get away from something but
quarterbacks usually gets hit while he
stands still so when you and you get out
you're out weighed by at least 100 plus
pounds all the time so they stopped that
a little bit of uh
you know compression into the ground and
i think that's where most guys got hurt
so uh taking that away allows you to
yeah physically
there's somebody at the door
the connection's not very good there joe
uh hold on for a sec i want to make sure
you get in the plug here uh
we'll see if we can reconnect with joe
there by the way joe just turned 65 a
couple of months ago and uh he's teamed
up with well care he's providing tips on
how to choose medicare plan stay healthy
at 65 and beyond